we're in the Toyota green when we are
live and in color with brian kelly he's
founder and CEO of the points guy it's a
website that tracks 43 programs to see
which ones offer the best value per mile
or point he joins us now with tips on
how you - you can get the best deal
ahead of a busy holiday travel season
that's coming up good morning to you
Brian to be here before we know it you
promise it is yeah but before we start I
think people should see your shoes oh
these are you know things any way we
could get my protective walls you know
when you travel as much as I do you need
as many protective spirits help yes
explain the look because I noticed
there's no socks no sock which I'm Gayle
we got to squeeze out every last bit of
what all the cool guys are doing you
know no socks yeah okay so let's think
about this Brian here we are August
what's the data I just ask somebody
August 28th 2019 summers ending were 92
days from Thanksgiving 119 days from
Christmas so when should we be booking
our trips it seems seems like this is so
far out to book it seems that way but I
so for if you're going anywhere
international over Thanksgiving or
Christmas holiday New Year you should be
booking now because international
flights usually three months is of the
sweet spot and then they just get more
and more expensive domestic flights
you're looking six to eight weeks so you
got a little bit of breathing room but
you know as we head into September you
should really start monitoring for deals
and into the airline's these days they
come out with flash sales that's what
we've been seeing all the major airlines
so like yesterday for example United had
twenty five thousand miles to go to
Hawaii but for one day only so you got
to be you know monitor the situation and
when you see one of these deals you got
a straight or grab it up this was what
bugs me I was looking for a flight you
know just doing an inquiry on Monday it
was one price yesterday it was another
price and it was higher yep you know you
can be searching for a flight and if
someone else is in the same process it
can actually pull the fare bucket and
cause your your price to jump which
we've all had that maddening experience
so you know there's a lot of conspiracy
theories out there to get clean the
airlines don't actually increase your
price but it's basically you know so
many other people like that's when the
prices go up I know a lot of people
think if I search for flight then the
airlines out to get me in there
it's not quite like that but it can seem
that way but are you here to say though
the earlier you book your flight to
better price you'll get so domestically
airlines they know they're nervous
Nellie's out there that one a book nine
months in advance my family reunion and
I'm just gonna book in the price because
it is stressful to think as the date
goes on but in general you know that six
to eight week mark is where they'll
start to and then they start to raise
the prices for business travelers they
really want to gouge that's why I like
last-minute travels always so crazy
expenses a quicker have to do a funeral
Sakhalin because the airlines are out to
gouge business travelers because
corporate travel is gonna send someone
who needs to go on a flight regardless
of price and price and they know that so
that six to eight week mark in general
is the sweet spot the time you should
start but also the days in which you
travel make a huge difference as well if
you want to travel on a Thursday and
come back Sunday that's good you know
that's expensive because everyone wants
to leave Thursday Friday come back on a
sigh so when should we go if you're
doing the weekend you know I would I
mean for the actual Thanksgiving you
know first flight out on Thursday I know
it sounds risky but you know the best
time to travel in general I'm not an
early bird but the first flight out of
almost any Airport almost always goes
out on time because you know there's not
those delays you know the day of you
know holidays if you fly out early
morning like the prices can be half as
much as flying out the night before so
sometimes you got to put a value how
much they really need me at yeah not
that much but generally speaking you say
booked the first flight out booked the
first flight out regardless holidays
whatever okay head to the airport first
because those first flights they don't
have the air traffic delays that you
know especially in cities like New York
where you know at 7 p.m. at LaGuardia
there's there's a traffic down that
runway yeah but the first flight outs
are generally like that those are pretty
much any airline internationally the the
best chances of getting to where you
want to go on time I also heard Brian
that you should buy your tickets on a
Tuesday before noon you know that was
the old you know the old way that
Airlines used to list fares it was you
know Tuesdays and then the other
airlines would react so Tuesday
Wednesday is where the right time
nowadays airlines have computer models
that price it instantly and you know
fares will change you know even in a
single day so that's not necessarily
true
and last month you we were talking about
how people have miles and so many of
them go on you go on you yeah I know why
cuz when you go to claim them it's a big
pain in there to know what it's a big
pain in the butt but that's why I like
the same thing with fair so the airlines
will actually run flash sales using
miles as well it's actually just this
week Delta Vacations just announced
until this Saturday the 30th I think now
you get double the value of your mile so
you get two cents per mile when booking
packages through Delta Vacations so if
you have a hundred thousand delta miles
that's two thousand dollars oh yeah and
flight and hotel
yeah r-rita I was our viral post this
week cuz a lot of people have Delta
miles and don't you know usually you're
getting one cent per mile you know fifty
thousand miles is gonna get you a $500
flight if you're lucky yeah with this
Delta Vacations deal you know it's a
flash deal this week only you get double
the value of your miles so I'm talking
about these flash sales how do we how do
we point scale recover we always cover
Bo I've walked right into that see that
coming but no but no sir we've covered
on our site but sign up you know any
loyalty program or airline follow them
there are other sites like airfare
watchdog secret fly big stick with the
points guys I know no but there's others
out there that you could well just stick
with that okay and top destinations if
you're looking for a deal yeah quick
getaway holiday getaway where to go so
consistently in the in the US cheap
flight wise New Orleans is really June
it's New Orleans in Portland Oregon and
in Portland actually just came in number
two on our best airport survey that we
just did
so I recommend also taking a road trip
to you can have a lot of fun rental cars
can be expensive but always rent off
airport there's also new apps like
churro I all my employees are obsessed
whenever they travel so Toro is
basically car sharing so my employees
like for the price of what a sedan would
be I saw one of my ploys on Instagram
driving a Range Rover Sport and I was
like who approved this on the expense
report and he looked and it's so
basically people app fancy cars can rent
them out to people you can get Tesla's
so at you know you're one of those kind
of bosses who approved for my employees
I want that car while I'm in the Prius
in my like turn is it a Range Rover but
but you I think a lot of times we think
we have to fly everywhere but especially
even in the Northeast or so many cool
places just you know an hour to outside
of New York I like all of your advice
and I like you too but there's I just
don't understand your advice but don't
check your bag well how can people
travel no I mean out checking a bag so
it's not like never check your bag of
course you know but you say try not to
check your bag well if you're bringing
tons and tons of stuff where do close by
I know well I think that that tip was
more so around like if your trouble with
a ton of gifts for the holidays I'm
shipping in advance is cheaper than what
the airline's gonna charge you you don't
have to worry about the bag not showing
up although airlines have gotten better
with the bags but no I mean look I'm the
size 14 shoe when I'm going away for two
weeks like I'm checking a bag when I go
you know 14 is a very big shoe just
saying it is two pairs of shoes in my
big feet and there's nothing worse than
waiting in line and missing your flight
what's your best waiting I know we're
going we're going it's about we want to
avoid waiting in the waiting line I hate
waiting line so you gotta get so if you
get Global Entry it's a whole yes yes
just look it's a pain in the butt you
gotta fill out a form ya know the
government is a very good tip clear have
you heard a clear my next tip because I
love clear so clear so love it my first
okay sorry sorry
No so anyway Global Entry is amazing
cuts for a hundred bucks you get it for
five years yes that means that any time
you come internationally you skip
through yeah also get you pre Chuck yeah
it's excellent and then in addition
clear I love clear if you have it even
if you just have a delta frequent flyer
account it gets cheaper with the lead
status so Delta United frequent flyers
get a discount clear is awesome because
it's biometric so you don't even need to
put your ID yep so at LaGuardia you know
even if you have pre checked you know
all those business travelers subcreature
no breach check used to be a very short
line but now a lot of people you know
everyone has pre-check so T it's so
clear is the new pre-check so clear you
put your two fingers and they actually
escort you to the front end every check
rises so if you want to use clear that
you got to have thick skin because
everyone will glare at you as you likes
that's why it's good to have an S
court yes because it shows I'm not
cutting the line yeah I have clear I'm
playing by the rules in this person is
taking me alright that I think that's
the best to clear and also it's not just
Airport so clear also works at Yankee
Stadium
so that long line to go through security
know that we're you get a bunch of new
stadium the more you know go why are you
gonna know I like you Brian thank you
for coming I like your shoes I like it's
a size 14 to learn more vines travel
tips and tricks visit the points guy
calm bye bye